I did all my tattooing backwards I look
mad funny I had nothing on my arms and
then I just had like this [ __ ] on my
hands right then I had like cuff ones on
my face I got my first tattoo when I was
16 I just turned 16 my friend he got
sick he caught meningitis they took his
leg from him so I got that one right
here it says tomorrow is another day but
it's not promised with some old clouds
and I paid like 200 for it
I shouldn't have paid that price I think
it was my eyelids and this anchor but it
was like I got three nothing cuz they
didn't hurt that's why I got ended up
getting somebody on my face like I even
got the rose all at one time like cuz
it's the weirdest thing but it's like it
doesn't hurt my mom's been a m-- on my
face
she'll be yes like my favorite one she
kept trying to get me to stop getting
face tats but then I was like I'm gonna
get one more so she couldn't really save
my family one thing my mom knew about me
with tats it's had some music is that
it's just what I was gonna do regardless
like she started realizing that she just
accepted it and loving me for me you
know
Japanese creative genius and cold heart
put us backwards so you can't read it
people that can actually read this out
like what's it say it like cold
heartening to be like this says you're a
genius you creator like alright cool so
they could tell her just like yeah you
ought to spell about results like I
didn't want nobody be able to like me
what I was doing my hand I got a lot of
[ __ ] on it that I could just look at
everyday and be like okay this is I
remember this what it took sacrifice I
got pain so I got music love life for me
learning the life love myself more I got
I love myself more they someone think
I'm learning to love my life more and I
am very thankful of everything
fill me yeah oh yeah Waze is my big one
shout out the Wiz Wiz is [ __ ] crazy
bro like this man he don't really have
no room at all I got like stories and
[ __ ] just going on all over his body
always wanted when I seen was Berlin how
he was tired I always knew one day like
I'm gonna be like that one day do you
know I got a lot of tats I still got a
lot of space oh my god music notes right
here I got these buildings it's like
ancient buildings gone right here I've
got 16s one of my favorite numbers
there's Nefertiti the queen of Egypt
oh my got it because Tupac I used to see
Tupac were like the necklace and [ __ ] I
got my favorite customer right here says
[ __ ] I got immortal right here because I
be feeling like [ __ ] not from this
planet through butterfly people no skies
loves the butterflies this one right
here is like one actually this one
doesn't mean anything this this guy on
me pulled up in my crib or whatever II
but he was like you know I just really
want to do this one I was like bet let's
do it
I got a couple recently that just don't
mean anything because I have so many
meaningful ones I was like I got it
let's do something for fun
so I got like a smiley face thing right
here I got loser on my leg on a locker
I've got this it's just a light I would
have playboy on it
the Playboy bunny knighting day these
two girls right here in a thong no bro I
love this [ __ ] it's like one of my
favorite I got to get more like [ __ ]
like this colors because these colors
are really good together this was on my
last merch a lot of people was like what
the [ __ ] is this when I went on tour
people didn't understand this right here
they're like they didn't even know if it
was my merch so I had to like post this
on my stories like yeah this is mom
where'd she go get it you did
I just got I'm a girl like her boobs and
[ __ ] out I'm thinking about getting the
color then just cause like it's bigger
[ __ ] I think it's gonna take like five
hours so that's why I've been like
debating and [ __ ] because I'm like I
said do that again it's just painful bro
that's something people like oh you like
in tax I do but it hurts Brian call I
learned something by myself because
where are you going through pain
thrilled especially this [ __ ] I'm
getting dug in my armpits [ __ ] all these
buildings and should I just got added
everything was all at once all of that
[ __ ] I even got like some shading down
here my clouds got some of them dark in
my stomach which is all just very
uncomfortable but I fought through it
and I made it I guess that's like the
best war for me is making it through a
tattoo